it is mother's day this weekend on
sunday of course so we wanted to share
pictures of our moms with you like
you've shared with us absolutely yeah so
we're going to start off with heather
and your mama oh
sweet john your mom
my sister
uh so my mom has been gone for about 20
years but that was a nice picture from
back when i got that's my mama she's
been gone since 2017. yeah there's
bianca's
one parents our directors backstage
annie one of our amazing producers and
chris christie
another director for the morning team
there's daryl here daryl
behind the scenes technical director
orion our executive producer and his
mama
and there's viv well you can't see viv's
face because she's giving mama a smooch
yeah that's all right though don't
forget you can also send us your
pictures as we head into mother's day at
pixpx 8newsnow.com
uh phone calls cost nothing
but flowers and spa treatments they go a
long way as well and a hug if you're
close by to mom and you can do that that
counts too happy mother's day bye
everyone have a great weekend everyone